[Música]
[Música] extranjera
acercándose desde las dos en punto a nuestro barco
y 30 segundos después nuestro timón se
dañó por lo que atacó directamente el
timón no nadando alrededor del barco no
jugando con nada corren a
toda velocidad contra un timón
extranjero
incluso hoy  Recibimos información de un
funcionario que decía que encienda el motor distraerá a
las orcas y otros dijeron que
apague el motor, no siga su
atención y luego algunos funcionarios dicen que se
mantengan o no más cerca de los
aviones de envío, donde hay más tráfico y profundidad, y
otros dicen que se queden donde  es shellware, por lo que el
consejo es muy confuso y no ayuda
en absoluto,
buena suerte.